Christmas is supposed to be a gift to
the retail trade but the High Street
took a hammering
in High Wycombe there was no dressing up
the Slowdown December normally is
supposed to be okay you know should be
good but there this year is a very
disappointing 50 you know down say sale
is down here especially in the in
January January is uh very tough
in the most crucial month of the
shopping year inflation strikes and
caution so consumers spend selectively
even when splashing out possibly fewer
customer numbers but there is still
people coming in to spend the money on
special gifts and special presents
retail sales volumes that's the amount
of stuff we bought fell by one percent
in December and year on year volumes
were down a record 5.8 percent
sales of classic Christmas presents like
Cosmetics sports equipment games toys
watches and jewelry were down 6.2
percent and whatever we bought we paid
more for Less since April 2021 the value
of sales that's the red line here and
the volume in yellow have diverged as
inflation cut consumer spending power
all the core Essentials food and energy
is where most of the money that
consumers are spending is going and of
course non-essential Goods you know the
discretionary items the big ticket items
are the ones where the the sales have
suffered most
the figures reflect the everyday
experience of millions like these
Shoppers in Oxford for whom cutting
spending is the only option we've got a
family of 12 and we decided that they
all had everything they wanted so he
gave them a pair of socks each and they
were very pleased every street corner
that you go on it just seems like it
keeps going up and up every Everything
really
um you know so it's it's tough It's hard
I'm so young and I still live at home so
I have the I don't really have to spend
my own money that much but my mum she
works really hard minimum wage job so
yeah not great the economic data may
suggest inflation has finally peaked but
out here it doesn't feel like it
essential food and fuel prices are still
rising and the value of people's wages
is falling so in the real world the cost
of living squeeze is going to have a
very long tail
2023 may see the economic pain ease but
the road to next Christmas already looks
a long one Paul Kelso Sky News